what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the heartbreaking aftermath
of the ua trader reveal how this
completely changes the class 1a dynamic
that we used to love and i will talk
about izaba's secret master plan to trap
the villains using the ua trader mha is
in the end game now and deku especially
is carrying a lot of weight if you know
what i mean so let's get into it if you
enjoy our boku no hero videos and you
want us to keep it going do me a quick
favor just leave a like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
with the youtube algorithm and if you
want a completely free way to directly
support this channel just take a second
to subscribe hit the bell and then
select the option that says all you
might think that's not a big deal who
cares if one person subscribes but
actually on youtube that means a lot you
can also hit me up on twitter and or
instagram at animeopror this video will
of course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the previous
chapter ended with aoyama and his family
being interrogated by the authorities
and with deku reaching out his hand to
aoyama and telling him that he can still
be a hero the latest chapter is called
the story of how we all became heroes
part 1 and it really focuses on class 1a
and how they are all dealing with the
fact that one of their own was the ua
traitor back in the interrogation room
sansa the kitty cat cop covers ayama's
mouth so that he can't talk as he
continues to cry tsukauchi then
hilariously points out to deku that
aoyama is currently restrained so he
can't take deku's hand i mean obviously
deku's point was mostly symbolic but
it's still funny to see tokauchi
bringing deku back to reality in more
ways than one at the end of the day no
matter how much sympathy deku and the
others might feel for aoyama and his
plight he's still been working with all
for one for years and he directly
assisted in some of his crimes and even
though the cops don't think that aoyama
was rigged with a self-destruction quirk
like lady nagant was they still think
it's better to keep him from talking
just in case something he says ends up
triggering some sort of trap that all
for one has set up honestly this might
seem a bit cruel at first glance because
aoyama is clearly remorseful but not
only was lady nagant booby trapped as
you will recall so was kurogiri he had
been rigged to completely pass out if he
ever started revealing any important
information about the villains so it's
possible that aoyama has some sort of
trigger as well tsukauji then asks
yuga's parents why they never told all
for one about the hero raiden camino
back then the villains were caught by
surprise and as a result all for one had
to emerge out into the open and this
ultimately led to his imprisonment if
the villains had had prior intel about
the raid things could have turned out
very differently the aoyama has
explained that they had no way of
reaching out to offer one at that time
it seems that they can only speak to him
if he reaches out to them first so they
had no way of telling him anything
unless he contacted them directly and
while this might prevent alpha-1 from
getting all of the important info that
he could have wanted in real time it
also protects him from being found out
if the aoyamas are ever discovered this
means that the aoyamas literally have no
way of contacting or locating all for
one it doesn't matter what the police do
to them they could even torture them but
the aoyamas will never be able to
provide any useful intel on all for one
location i mean it's kind of brilliant
to be honest and it's exactly the type
of thing that you would expect from a
criminal mastermind however multiple
members of class 1a believe that they
can still use aoyama and his status as
the ua trader to gain an advantage over
all for one kaminari mineta momo and
others seem ready to forgive aoyama just
like deku or at least they seem to be
willing to give him a chance at
redemption president mike is like okay
hold up and he tries to warn them that
they can't just start trusting aoyama
now after he deceived them for so long
but then even ida jumps in and says that
they have to let bygones be bygones okay
what eda the guy who is known for being
a stickler for the rules who is the
class representative wants to forgive
the ua trader so quickly like it's
nothing the same ua trader who put his
entire class that he is responsible for
in danger multiple times honestly i was
not a fan of this at all i can
understand deku's behavior because
that's kind of who he's always been and
i know that eda has evolved since the
beginning of the series in terms of
always following the rules to the letter
but i still feel that some of the class
1a students are too eager to forgive
aoyama way too quickly i mean i know
that horikoshi wants to give aoyama some
form of redemption and i'm totally fine
with that happening eventually but
shouldn't aoyama's classmates take some
time to actually process their feelings
before just forgiving him on the spot am
i the only one who feels that this is
happening way too quickly i never
thought i'd say this but to me bakugou
sounds like the voice of reason on this
one he says that he's gone through hell
because of aoyama which is true and he
just wants to blow oyama up with like
five howitzer impacts that totally makes
sense he's reacting like a normal person
under the circumstances but then cerro
tells him that he's being too harsh and
kirishima goes on to yell out a bunch of
stuff at aoyama but the gist of what he
yells out is essentially that he also
believes that they can move past this
then aizawa facetimes everyone from the
hospital and he takes full
responsibility for not seeing that one
of his own students was operating as the
ua trader right under his nose but
isabel then goes on to say something
that i really don't know how to feel
about he tells ayama that he has no
intention of expelling him from ua
instead he has devised a plan izawa
proceeds to tell tsukauji to cover up
the ears of the aoyamas so that he can
reveal the plan to the others presumably
this plan will involve aoyama but izawa
doesn't want him to know about the plan
just yet in case all for one still has
some way of extracting information from
him unfortunately we don't get to hear
this secret plan yet although by the
reaction of those in the room who did
hear it it seems to be an intriguing and
very consequential plan according to
nezu it is also a very practical plan
but tsukauji doesn't know if they should
even attempt it at any rate the class 1a
students are told to keep the plan
secret from everyone else and then
aoyama and his family are taken to the
police hq as the students look on also
ochako has her hair tied up so you know
things are about to go down back inside
the dorms the students are trying to
come to terms with everything that
happened and they are also preparing to
execute aizawa's mysterious plan all the
remaining class 1a students pledge to
defeat the villains and they all have
serious and intense looks on their faces
deku has a serious and intense look as
well and since he and ita need new hero
costumes after their current ones were
damaged they head to meet up with the
one and only mei hatsume the full-time
genius inventor and part-time deranged
mad scientist deku knows that in order
to prepare for the next big villain
battle he has to be in top shape and so
does all of his gear and so he maintains
that intense look as he tries to enter
may's workshop but he is suddenly blown
to the ground along with the door after
an intense explosion just randomly goes
off inside the workshop the last page of
the chapter shows mei lying on top of
deku her oppai right in deku's face and
although hida is like what the [ __ ] deku
is still maintaining that same intense
look on his face as mei's oppai pressed
down upon him and that is how this
chapter ends okay okay i'll be real with
you guys i am not a huge fan of this
chapter but that moment where deku is
still maintaining a serious look as
mei's oppai crush his face made me laugh
out loud that is some iron-willed
determination right there this man will
not let anything distract him from his
mission and i respect that that said
though as i mentioned earlier i'm not a
fan of so many students being willing to
forgive aoyama so quickly like yes
bakugou is still holding it down and to
be fair we haven't heard from all the
different students individually but to
have so many students act like aoyama
didn't just put all of them and their
teachers and other people in direct
danger for like a year is just
unrealistic again i can totally
understand if eventually over time they
can come to forgive him after he helps
them fight against the villains and
redeems himself but this just feels
rushed i get that horikoshi is trying to
move the story along but we have to get
a proper emotional progression after
five years of wondering who the ua
trader is i mean how do you guys feel
about this am i overreacting when i say
that this felt rushed and unrealistic or
do you agree with me the most
interesting thing about this chapter to
me is isawa's secret plan which almost
certainly involves aoyama trying to use
his status as the ua traitor to deceive
all for one and the villains when isabel
first said that he's not going to expel
aoyama i thought it was just another
example of people forgiving him way too
easily because it was convenient for the
plot but when aizawa says that he has a
plan and that the aoyamas cannot hear
what that plan is yet i realized that
keeping aoyama at ua and acting like
everything is normal is probably part of
isa's plan to lure the villains into a
trap if they were to expel aoyama now
the villains would immediately know that
the traitor has been compromised but
will this mysterious plan actually work
with all for one being as careful as he
is i guess it all depends on the nature
of eiza's secret plan but i'm very
curious to find out what exactly he has
in mind we know that all for one has
like 10 plans and backup plans going at
the same time so the heroes definitely
do need to put their own plans into
motion before it's too late what do you
guys think isawa's secret plan is and
what exactly will it try to accomplish
is it going to involve using the traitor
to make all for one thing that deku is
out alone somewhere but then it turns
out that it's a trap set by the heroes
will it be something else definitely
share your thoughts down in the comments
below the reveal of the ua trader has
definitely shifted the dynamic between
the class 1a students and they will
probably never be as trusting of each
other as they once were that of course
is to be expected the innocent and naive
class 1a students we once knew are gone
the class 1a students we see now are
becoming battle hardened and experienced
heroes and they have gone through some
truly terrifying and tragic ordeals and
it is for this reason that i hope
horikoshi won't just have everyone
forgive aoyama so easily because after
everything that happened that just
wouldn't make sense give it some time
allow the class to deal with what
happened have aoyama actually do
something to redeem himself and then
let's talk about forgiveness the class
1a students we see today are much more
mature and experienced than the students
we used to know and so their reaction to
the ua trader reveal has to reflect that
i mean people have died cities have been
destroyed and forgiveness must be earned
at least that's my two cents
if you guys enjoyed this video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like it only takes a second but it
really helps with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking
subscribe hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says all if
you don't do that you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thanks to
alpha sigma this man is an absolute mad
lad and a disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata al-jatal
pate heffa the red-haired fox hinokamien
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
spike lonely dakar dylan isadore spidey
life tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy cummins and che whitley finally
thank you also to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell crews very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
alivania and temple if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you